everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're in around nine
of our coverage of the 2016 Tata Steel
tournament our competitors today why
it's going to be played by the 16 year
old prodigy from China wayi playing a
pretty good tournament so far his
opponent David navara the Czech Republic
Grandmaster probably had the biggest
upset of the tournament last round
beating fabiano caruana in the leaders
we have magnus carlsen in first place
and fabiano in second place they were
tied for a while but after that slip to
Damon avarra in the last round fabiano
is now in second place so both of our
compares two day away in both David
navara both have four points out of the
possible eight so going into round nine
both of them looking for a strong
performance if they can start to climb
up at the leaderboard so we'll start out
way he plays pawn to e4 Ponte 59 if
three and 96 Bishop to b5 and then a
knight to f6 so getting into the Berlin
defense something with we've seen more
and more frequently magnus carlsen
really started playing it a lot against
vision on in the world championships and
ever since then we see it popping up
more and more in Grand Master play now
for a white usually has a few options
from here magnus carlsen really likes
the castling on the King side that's
kind of the open variation but we see
kind of a little different approach from
wait year plays pawn to d3 now two ways
that black can kind of respond a one is
to kind of play a pretty aggressive
Bishop here to see five and the other
one is pawn to d6 sort of a mayor of
what White's doing he apps for the more
aggressive line Bishop here to see five
and then what usually if you kind of
seen this opening in the past you'd
normally see a pawn to c3 either one a
Dem matter if it's pawn of these six or
Bishop here to see five pawn to c3 is
pretty common instead we see a new
variation that that seems to be pretty
exciting to play and that's the bishop
taking here on c6 probably a smite
slight improvement over the pond here to
see three so after the pawn takes here
on c6 we see night to d2 now if you kind
of look at and say well this pawn right
here just looks right for the taking
for the night here on e5 this would
definitely be a mistake after Knight to
e5 then the Queen could come down here
to d4 looking at the checkmate here on
f2 why it's kind of forced to stop this
with either Bishop to e3 we could have
King castle on the kingside a few
options there but all in all this night
here is going to fall on e5 so that's
going to be very very bad so instead we
see night here to d2 castle on the Kings
side and the night up here to a d4 same
logic would apply why the night could
not take care on e5 the Queen's just
going to come down here to d4 now we can
see night to a c4 and this is adding a
real attacker since we where I talked
about this nights not going to take here
on e5 but this night here potentially
could this night here at f3 is still
protecting the square and d4 where the
Queen would like to come to so this
night attacking it now kind of forces
black to start to defend this square you
can defend it with night here to g4 he
can defend it with night here to d7 he
could also defend it with rook here to
e8 he opts for night here to d7 I really
like the the more aggressive night here
to g4 still opens up the door for the
light square Bishop to easily get
involved it doesn't block it off but
decides to go forward night here to d7
and then Queen to e2 just continuing his
development doesn't want to block off as
dark for a bishop still leaving himself
open he could castle on the King side he
could castle on the queenside so very
very nice opening it really looks like
wait he is really prepared for this
variation I'm not really sure David
Navarre so much has seen this variation
so devorah continues with rook to e8
putting a more protection on the square
here on e5 bishop here to d2 completing
his development and then Bishop back to
d6 just adding another layer of
protection and you can kind of tell from
black he's not exactly sure what white
has up his sleeve so he's kind of been
complete defensive mode he's not really
trying anything and so he's kind of just
waiting to see what why it's going to do
why decides to be pretty aggressive he
plays pawn here to age for more than
likely signifying that he's going to
Castle on the queenside start to push
forward on the King side so we see pawn
here to see five not doing a ton but
decides that he needs to start to do a
little bit on the queenside punt up here
to h5 upon to h6 stopping this attack a
little bit and then castle on the
queenside getting ready for the rook to
get involved into the action now if you
look at the the Queen work over here at
a 8 it's going to take a while for this
rook to actually get involved into the
action going to move the night first get
the light square Bishop involved
probably move the Queen first then
connect the rooks and even then it's not
clear how could really get involved into
the action in a way that's going to add
a lot of benefit so night back here to
be 8 and this is kind of where you feel
like David of ours just not completely
prepared for this opening he kind of
brought his night here to d7 now he's
bringing it back here to kind of
maneuver to c6 he's kind of studied the
board taking a little bit more time than
he probably liked in and saying okay I
need to readjust some things that don't
like my position now I've kind of
blocked off my light squared Bishop I
need to get my night to a place where
it's protecting this hearing the board a
little bit better so brings his night
back to be eight but you know way on the
other side he knows exactly what he's
doing he continues with his game plan of
let's throw everything on the King side
of the board and see what we can do so
Rick over here to a g1 night here to see
six and then pawn up here to g4 just
looking to push forward as much as
possible pawn here to f6 pushing even
more pawn here to g5 and then the pawn
captures and then night takes here on g5
and this is pretty interesting because
it's somewhat tough for the pond to take
here on g5 we're now going to see the
bishop take more than likely from here
the bishops going to come here to e7 the
bishop could capture the Queen
recaptures upon up here to h6 this gets
pretty tricky you probably don't want to
play pawn here to g6 because it's this
pawns not protected so just look here to
g6 check that's going to be bad no
protection in front of the king you have
to Brooks over here or pawn you can
easily get your queen involvement of the
game asking
bad but if you do play the pawn here to
g5 it does have protection from the
Queen here Abba now the queen heir to h5
back it's dangerous you can push a
little further with pond h7 you can push
here with you know queen here to g6
depending on what black does you could
take the pawn here on g5 with either
your rook or your queen it gets really
really difficult for black to kind of
hold on to so black found another
variation which I also don't really like
but he played night here to d4 forcing
the Queen back but the Queen's on a
similar square d 1 is still protecting
and attacking the square here on age
five and now black decides that he wants
to go ahead and roll the dices and play
pong taking here on g5 ok so giddy up
the bishop takes here on g5 the Bishop
to e7 and I think he could probably just
take here on e7 we kind of looked at a
variation just second ago of exactly
what that would look like he decides to
go ahead and hold on to it plays Bishop
here to e3 now Bishop to f6 pawn here to
h6 just pushing forward as much as
possible and then black continuous with
his I have no idea what to do even
though I'm playing in a rather large
tournament I'm really skilled player
plays real care to e7 another move that
I really don't like I never want to give
up all the pawns in front of my king
that just seems like a really bad idea
so let's look at some of his other
options he could play pawn here to g6
that's probably the worst just rook here
to g6 check that's going to be really
bad if we play that the pawn to g5 a
little bit different variation but we
could still see the bishop take here on
g5 if the bishop retakes then pond up
here to f4 this gets really brutal the
bishop can't take right here because the
rook pinning down the bishop to the king
right here if the Pawn were to take then
it gets really difficult with the Queen
to h5 you would kind of like a
discovered attack with pawn to f3 but
then the bishops just going to fall upon
here to f3 and then all of a sudden
check and then it's it's just really
difficult for for black to have to deal
with that so if we
come back you know even after here we
see the King come to HH rook takes here
on g5 that was going to fall could try
something creative night here to e to
check move the king but then all in all
black is going to be forced to resign
there's no way to stop all of this
threats if you kind of look at it look
at all these powerful pieces over here
that black has never even gotten
involved into the game so after pawn to
age six we see rook to e7 wants to go
ahead and give up that material so
what'd you decide hey yeah I'll go ahead
and take that material that's fine with
me so after the rook takes then we're
going to see the Queen get involved into
the game so Queen here to h5 and then we
see the Bishop to e6 just wants to get
more material involved into the game
plays Bishop to a6 probably much better
in this position it was a pretty intense
variation you have to go through a lot
of calculations who you probably keeping
it a lot easier but from here you could
have played just queen here 2 h8 after
this it's kind of a forced move you have
keen to f7 now the rooks going to take
bishop could recapture now night taking
here on e5 check forcing kind of a
capture here ruke appear to h7 the Kings
going to force to move you can kind of
maneuver a little bit all of a sudden
the bishops going to fall the Queen just
kind of forced to maneuver and help as
much as possible but after some checks
and then you can see the bishop take
here all in all you're going to see more
material fall on board the Queen's
eventually going to followers going to
give up a checkmate on board so this is
going to be extremely bad for for blaka
it probably would have been a little
faster win but decided to instead play a
safer route that yet didn't have to
think too much about and that was bishop
here to h6 but his opponent just
continues to not play the optimal moves
be really didn't have a chance in this
position anyway but Bishop here to f7
Bishop takes here on g7 Bishop takes the
Queen that's fine Bishop takes here on
f6 discovered attack forcing the king to
have protection or move and also attack
the Queen here on d6 so King here to f8
Bishop takes Knight down here too
to decides it wants to go ahead and get
material right here but then after the
bishop takes here on a c7 then we do see
a resign from black there's just no way
to stop white he has kind of everything
covered if the bishop moves because the
bishops being attacked by the rook the
rooks was going to come here to g1
capture this material he has more pawns
on board he has way more material going
into the in-game that's going to be an
easy game if he moves the Knights the
Bishop's going to fall if he tries you
know Rick over here to see eight Bishop
here to d6 check the king is forced to
move then you could just start to take
more much he'll it could take either of
the night could take the bishop it
starts to take pawns off the board all
in all just complete utter domination by
white so black decides to go ahead and
resign in this position so a really
impressive game probably the entire
tournament so far from what I've seen
that the most impressive performance
really fascinating how he prepared for
this game a slight variation from the
normal Berlin defense as far as how
white attacks that led to just a
complete surprise black had no idea how
to defend it all in all 16 year old came
out and dominated so he's kind of moved
up the charts five points out of 9 a
really good performance from him magnus
carlsen still at the top but all in all
a fantastic round so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this exciting around and I'll
see you guys in the next one thanks for
watching